problema número 129 en un viaje reciente
gabi condujo su auto 290 kilómetros
aproximadamente
esta es una cantidad de redondeada y uso
12 litros aproximadamente que también es
una cantidad de redondeada
la cantidad exacta de litros por
kilómetro usados por gabi estará en qué
rango de cantidades los datos que nos
dan son 290 kilómetros y uso
aproximadamente 12 litros
esto está redondeado así que sus
kilómetros debieron ser 285 porque 285
se redondea hacia 290
menor o igual su kilometraje y esto a su
vez debe ser menor a 295 que también si
es menor a 295 se redondea 290 la misma
lógica aplica para los litros la
cantidad de litros que gastó gabi se
encuentra entre 11.5 litros esa cantidad
es menor o igual a los ritos usados que
a su vez es menor que 12.5 litros estos
redondeados estas cantidades al
redondear se nos dan 12 cuál será la
menor cantidad de kilómetros por litro
pueden hacer la menor cantidad de
kilómetros entre la mayor cantidad de
litros la menor cantidad de kilómetros
son 285
la mayor cantidad de litros es 12.5 12.5
y se aproxima a este valor pero no lo
alcanza los kilómetros por litros serán
mayores que esto
nuestros kilómetros por litro serán
mayores que estos pero no iguales y la
mayor cantidad de kilómetros por litro
será la mayor cantidad de kilómetros
entre la menor cantidad de litros esto
será menor que 295 kilómetros entre 11.5
litros aunque nunca alcanzará esta
cantidad veamos las opciones y la más
cercana a la que tenemos aquí es la de
que dice 284 / 12.5 menor a los
kilómetros por litro que es menor a su
vez a 295 / 11.4
estos números que calculamos se
encuentran en este rango que es de la
opción de así que siguen siendo válidos
nuestros rangos y esta es la opción
resultado veamos el siguiente problema
número 130 cuál de las siguientes
desigualdades es una expresión
algebraica de la parte sombreada en la
siguiente recta numérica tenemos esta
recta numérica que tiene el valor 3 aquí
tiene el valor de menos 5 y esta es la
parte que está resaltada podemos decir
qué
este rango que me interesaba de menos 5
es menor o igual a x cualquier valor de
x que cumple con esto estará en este
rango y que a su vez x sea menor o igual
a 3 pero esta no es una opción pues lo
quieren en términos de valor absoluto y
cuando en una recta hablamos de valores
absolutos nos referimos a la distancia
entre estos puntos y de menos 5 a 3
hay una longitud de 8 aquí hay 8
unidades de distancia y ambos van a
estar a la misma distancia de menos 1
-1 y agregó si recorro a partir de menos
14 lugares a la derecha llegó a 3 y si
recorro cuatro lugares a la izquierda
llegaré al menos 5
forma de pensar en ello es que la
diferencia de xy menos 1 la diferencia
de x menos menos 1 que es mi punto
intermedio sin importar si x va hacia la
izquierda o hacia la derecha del -1 esta
diferencia en valor absoluto que es lo
que me piden debe ser menor o igual a 4
que es el número máximo de elementos que
podemos recorrer a derecha oa la
izquierda sin salirnos de este rango y
esto lo podemos simplificar como x + 1
el valor absoluto de esto debe ser menor
o igual a 4 cualquier x que cumpla con
esto va a estar en este rango y esta es
mi opción
esto es algo útil de aprender ya que en
muchos exámenes cuando se habla de
valores absolutos se refieren a la
distancia en una dimensión de la recta
numérica en este caso de cada equis que
cumpla con esta x menos menos 1 menor
igual a 4 en valor absoluto estará en el
rango veamos el siguiente problema
problema número 131 una fábrica tiene
500 trabajadores 15% de ellos son
mujeres si se van a contratar 50
trabajadores adicionales y se mantienen
los actuales cuántos de los nuevos
trabajadores deberán ser mujeres para
aumentar el porcentaje al 20%
bueno cuántas mujeres tenemos
actualmente el total de trabajadores es
igual a 500
y el porcentaje de mujeres es el 15 por
ciento de este total punto 15 de 500
punto 15 por 500 igual a 75 para
encontrar la proporción de mujeres pues
tenemos que es 75 entre el total que es
que es 15
y el total le vamos a agregar 50 ya que
se van a contratar 50 personas 500 más
50 y aquí tenemos que ver cuántos de
esos 50 tendrán que ser mujeres para que
el porcentaje de esta proporción de 15
sea igual al 20% o al punto 2
vamos a desarrollar estos 500 más 50 es
550 vamos a multiplicar todo por 550 nos
queda 75 más m igual a 550 por punto 2
es igual a 110 110
vamos a restar 75 en ambos lados y nos
queda que m es igual a 110 menos 75 es
igual a 35 así que de las 50 personas
contratadas 35 tendrán que ser mujeres
para que se eleve el porcentaje de
mujeres al 20% esta es mi opción
veamos el siguiente problema problema
número 132
en una tienda de botanas el ingreso
promedio o la media aritmética de 10
días es de 400 si el ingreso promedio es
de 360 durante los primeros 6 días cuál
fue el promedio de ingreso de los cuatro
días restantes ya hemos resuelto muchos
problemas de este tipo primero tenemos
que ver cuál es el promedio total así
que vamos a multiplicar los primeros
seis días por su promedio de ingreso que
es de 160 más los siguientes 4 días por
su promedio que todavía no conozco cuál
fue el promedio de ingreso entre los 10
días del periodo y esto debe ser igual a
voy a multiplicar todo por 10 me queda 6
por 360 y ahorita verán porque todavía
no hago esta operación por 4 de este
promedio es igual a 400 x 10 4 mil
y ahora voy a dividir todo entre 4 si lo
dividen t4 esto va a pasar a hacer mil
esto va a pasar a ser p 4 el promedio
que busco y 360 entre 4 es igual a 90 90
por 66 por 90 ahora multiplico 6 por 90
va a ser igual a 540 540 más p 4 igual a
mil
resto 540 en ambos lados me va a quedar
que el promedio que estoy buscando es
igual a 1000 menos 540 va a ser igual a
460 este es el promedio de ingresos
durante los últimos 4 días del periodo y
es mi opción de
nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo